urban dictionary this must be a joke I'm
going to preface this by saying I
believe this is very likely to be a joke
okay herb that tire may so you know what
urban dictionary is yeah do you want to
sure I mean it's it's when you hear a
word that some young uns using some
savvy you know person that is using the
new slang and you have no idea what it
means you can check out urban dictionary
and it'll explain it to you and it's
great
you usually generated yeah you can it's
it's great actually I love it and for
everyone I know is used it please check
out this awesome
floor by was in the urban dictionary I
warm oh it should be somebody somebody
message to me that they that we're to
change the spelling to F le u RB e b ua
b b:e aux you did that I did that you
you know you created floor bow oh yeah
yeah and there's more soft right but you
did you all you did was just come up
with floor bow let me read this by you
doing that you you did that yes okay so
floor bow is a proper name to be used in
place of a pronoun here are some
examples
Sam identifies as non-binary with the
pronouns they them Sam I offended I'm
offended by the use of gendered language
John oh great floor bow is offended
again I wish that floor bow would shut
up already so I'm well that's assuming
they're referring to Sam Smith there's a
better example of that though so the two
examples for what floor bow is for those
that don't understand would be someone
says I am gender non-binary and use
they/them pronouns
mr. Shapiro says I am not a fan and I
would prefer not to use language that I
don't you know I don't recognize the
ideology you know behind
however in agreement to not offend
either party the debate moderator says I
will refer to you both as floor boat
yep that way no one has to use a word
other side is trying to make them use it
and and the floor bow was meant to
inspire image of like Kirby or like a
fluffy marshmallow man you know for some
like that you know I think I think like
you know flubber was probably like an
inspiration sure it's like what I was
thinking of like a little jelly jiggly
man who's happy and fun and bouncy and
bouncy and it was supposed to be kind of
a not you know kind of just like a no
one's really gonna be mad about it I
don't know so that was the idea and
urban dictionary ended up getting
getting an entry for it and many people
started using the word the general idea
is if you don't know what someone
identifies as instead of getting into a
position where they say actually my
pronouns are you say floor bow and if
they say my pronouns are whatever and
that's fine floor bow floor bow is a
word that's not part of any whatever and
we can have a none it was supposed to be
like there's no way to win an argument
when there's no fence to sit on so I
made that fence a merge those fent posts
in and I said floor bow is the middle so
say if I good for you okay well anyway
it got into urban dictionary has thrown
them in the towel you ready I'm going to
preface this by saying this may be a
joke because urban dictionary is like as
offensive as they come mmm-hmm but this
got published to Facebook they wrote 20
years ago urban dictionary started as a
place for everyone to share their
language it was intended to subvert the
authority of the traditional dictionary
and to document our messy weird and
unpredictable language as it evolved
everyday regular people add thousands of
definitions making it a living cultural
document since 1999 our community has
written over 12 million definitions we
are proud that urban dictionary has
become a source of laughter and an
irreplaceable reference made by and for
the people but over the years online
discourse has changed and so have the
words we're receiving like other online
platforms we've been inundated by hate
speech and abusive content targeting
women Vivek is that a typicai POC by POC
and lgbtqia+ and other vulnerable groups
hate speech and abusive content online
can cause real harm offline it can also
make people feel unsafe to speak up and
share their
language silencing entire groups of
people is it not what we want for our
platform to be for I'm gonna pause right
there and say therefore we're going to
be silencing large groups of people
hahaha they go on urban dictionary plays
an important role in defining language
on the internet and popular culture to
do this right and to earn the role
you've entrusted us with we need to make
sure our system measures up to our
values the site has always been a place
for people who define the messier edges
of language but we can't allow to foster
hate words matter it's kind of our whole
thing here but actions matter more so
that not that now we have bullet points
we will not allow Urban Dictionary to be
a home for hate speech and abuse of
content we support the work of black
lives matter to dismantle systemic
racism we accept our own responsibility
to fight racism and hate and acknowledge
that we have failed to keep abusive
content off the site we take this work
seriously and it is our priority we are
reviewing our core processes on how
words are added reviewed published and
removed we are investing in technology
and human review to better enforce our
standards we'll post updates on our
progress here we will change as hate
speech changes
no single fix will work forever hate
speech and abusive content will evolve
and we are committed to changing our
policies to meet it as we rethink the
dictionary we want to hear from you
Urban Dictionary is written by you and
we want you to be involved while we
decide what is and isn't acceptable on
it please share your thoughts in the
forum here there's a link in a few weeks
we'll share what we've learned from your
feedback I got one thing to say here
reform 2:30 boom reform 2:30 and this
which is very clearly not a joke yeah
yeah that's not a joke I know I just
have to say that because urban
dictionary is probably one of the most
offensive websites that exists
especially for a mainstream website yeah
like you can type in any racial slur and
get some of the most ridiculously racist
and offensive posts the whole thing yeah
they're there they're there are words
used in slang in the real world and
online that are racist is urban
dictionary going to start banning them
yeah racism exists you know it exists
no one no one says it doesn't exist
people are gonna make up new words man
you know there's a period where I don't
know exactly the full details
there were certain groups of people that
started using they replaced racial slurs
with words like Facebook Skype and
Twitter and so they would say things
like you know those Facebook's were
doing this or whatever and the gag was
that if they used the word to represent
a racial slur eventually like they can't
do anything about it because the
platforms can't ban their own name even
if they decided to ban certain Sneaky so
so so it's it's it's it's a guaranteed
win that was that was the idea because a
bunch of articles got written about it
saying like racists are using the names
of major brands as racial slurs what's
Facebook gonna do in certain contexts
our name is a banner bull offense they
can't do that it's their brand that's a
good point
they can't use a robot to do that so how
you actually stop people from doing it
they couldn't and so people did that's a
really good idea Tim no it's not a good
idea I'm saying something it's something
that happened and eventually died out
nobody cared anymore right but it like
cuz most people aren't racists right and
there was no big movement because nobody
but I think the issue with that idea is
probably a lot of these people probably
thought it would become a trend until
you realize most people aren't racist
and didn't want to use that language
yeah most people just don't like people
who suck stop being mean to my friends
like I mean you can make jokes and stuff
but this is it
urban dictionary is supposed to be about
jokes mm-hmm anymore what is urban
dictionary now you're gonna be like I'm
gonna make up a word called like more
more more Biff more Biff and it's when
you when you accidentally drop a
marshmallow in the campfire oh like boy
it's like we're becoming moral it's it
really is becoming that jokey Flanders
family yeah you know wow man that crazy
think about Ned Flanders and his kids
rod and Todd and how they're like it's
he goes oh okay kids it's seven o'clock
time for bed and they go yeah and they
run into bed and then shut the blinds
like there's all these weird moments in
the Simpsons where they're celebrating
really awful things so then there's
there's like one where Ned's like who
wants nachos and they're like and then
Bart Lisa run in and he goes Flanders
style that's cucumbers and cottage
cheese so that's what's happening no
is what we're gonna get I'll tell you
why our equilibrium our dictionary is
changing our Urban Dictionary is
changing the Libertarian Party is
endorsing it here's you know you know
the thing about the Libertarian Party
endorsing this is that's the most I
think insidious well they endorsed it
without even knowing what it was true
and that means a lot of people will and
once these ideas enter so it's the
Trojan horse the Libertarian Party says
yeah opposing racism is a good thing
endorses it out right then everyone sees
it as normal and then the people who run
these organizations say here's what it
means you got to do now mm-hmm so for
those that aren't familiar the
definition of racism has changed in the
actual dictionary they they created a
circular definition racism is one a
belief that raises the primary
determinant of human traits and capacity
capacities and that racial differences
produce an inherent superiority of a
particular race to a doctrine or
political program based on the
assumption of racism and designed to
execute its principles to be a political
or social system founded on racism three
racial prejudice or discrimination now
the problem with this and for many of
you may have heard this already Bob just
give me context because I got another
definition to show you basically what
they did because of political pressure
is they included systemic racism in the
definition of racism under the word
racism what they're describing these
definitions is systemic racism not
regular like not the word racism this
creates a circular definition because
they use the word in the definition of
itself right which means you create a
recursive loop so the dictionary would
read a political or social system
founded on a political or social system
founded on a political or and it would
never end it would just be an endless
recursion because they define the word
by itself now you could argue you can
use the diverse definition to define the
second definition but that makes
literally no sense and now I bring you
the best part about the change to our
dictionary this is Miriam Webster since
1828 this stuff is here it's here to
stay
ladies and gentleman I give you the word
homosexuality now sometimes offensive
see usage paragraph below - now
sometimes offensive see usage paragraph
below and the usage usage paragraph
below does not explain anything they're
just literally saying the word itself is
offensive so they don't even explain
what it means they don't explain why
it's offensive at all but I go back up
though the definition oh there it is
yeah sexual or romantic attraction to
others of one's same sex the quality or
state of being gay - is sexual activity
with another of the same sex but those
are both considered to be offensive in
certain contexts so they included that
that this word is offensive and you need
to understand the context to tear your
warning so now see this is this is what
I've been talking about they're making
it offensive by telling everyone it's
offensive now now it's like now they're
teaching that it is offensive that it is
a thing that racism is a thing that most
people are racist that you know I'm
obviously expanding on the idea but it's
the same they're just trying to convince
everybody now that it's not there change
there's nothing wrong with man sexuality
like some people are okay that's fine
who's offended by it why would they be
offended by well the this was actually
about to my attention by Arielle
Scarcella okay who was shelf was she
expended by it no she was confused by it
right and she was like I don't get it
right she's smart articulate and you
know and she's a lesbian yeah and it's
like okay I defer to her I would I do -
I do yeah she she speaks out a lot about
this kind of stuff and it makes no sense
you know the George Orwell quote which
run records were falsified street names
were changed history was erased yada
yada yeah I mean it's all literally
happening right now exactly the 16:19
project starts it has begun to rewrite
in erase our history
they started under that same pretext
painting our streets renaming our
streets a street in each of the five
boroughs in Newark has been renamed in
DC I think Chicago did the same thing
they're charging people with hate crimes
they're actually investigating it you
probably saw this yeah the car that
drove over the crosswalk they arrested
somebody for it you should they arrested
them I read that they actually arrested
someone for it I don't know if it's the
right person but it's crazy that you can
rip down statues of of people yeah you
know mayor no investigation founders
well there is now because of
Trump's right executive order but it's
you know - they have video footage of
the person you know peeling out over the
rainbow Street and it's a hate crime
it's like they weren't peeling out they
weren't and there's no evidence suggest
that right so there was a crosswalk and
it's in Canada mind you I think was
quite all right yeah was and the the the
crosswalk was painted because it's got
two white lines it was a rainbow in
between there was a tread mark across it
because a car turned it wasn't peeling
out no I wasn't I wasn't even going very
fast
I sometimes you leave tire marks that's
true maybe they were driving and he did
a hard turn it was an accident I have no
idea it actually happens naturally
they're actually they're actually
looking for this person they're
investigating and may have arrested them
for driving a car on the road you know
yeah and well like the the couple that
went out and painted over the B and the
L right I think hate crime I think they
were trying to change it to all lives
matter maybe I think over it in Chicago
they painted over the BL CK so the a was
still there and then they drew to white
L sawl I've met all lives matter and now
in New York they're doing they're
writing black lives matter in front of
the Trump building so I saw this I've
known that it was going on but on
Facebook there's this this mean that's
going around there like yeah take that
Trump and I'm like do you know how much
he's done for the minority community if
you don't know you haven't been to
paying attention and it's embarrassing
that's all I said to them I would I'd be
willing to bet a very large sum of money
that if we could develop a machine to
read Trump's mind and he cares not at
all about that about the gram painting
in front of it yeah no you don't tweeted
about it uh-huh saying it was a hate
message but I think the full context of
the tweet was that you've got crime
skyrocketing in New York and this is
what they do right this is where they're
putting their money basically so but but
you are getting killed every day they
roll with it like they say everyone
started posting like ah Trump's all
angry how we got him and Trump's
probably like hey they think I'm mad
about this yeah he loves keeping them so
so Trump recently tweeted something like
less than one one one 100th of something
yeah that made no sense
and everybody started making fun of him
for it he tweeted another typo and I'm
like he's doing they don't learn us it's
not even if he doesn't on purpose yeah
it's that whenever he puts a typo
actually let me put this way sometimes
in my youtube videos there will be a
typo that I'll miss mm-hmm I don't do it
on purpose but sometimes you know a few
hours later I'll see it and I'll laugh
and leave it you know why why because
when people see the typo in the headline
they go into the vo to make sure they
can comment and say I saw the typo
that's true so I don't do it on purpose
but Trump probably tweets out and then
an hour later sees his phone blowing up
and he sees the typo and he laughs and
leaves it because it's distracting
everybody that's true although I will
say in Trump's case I think he doesn't
sometimes on purpose yeah I think so too
there that the famous story was that he
tweeted about the squad going back to
their home countries and at the same
time he was ending like refugee and
asylum rules that were like pretty like
a bold move okay and the news cycle
did not care they were like how dare
Trump tweet this spur and then of course
a was seen Ilyn Omar were like how dare
Trump he is such a bigot meanwhile I saw
some journalists going like ah isn't
this story like this one way bigger
Trump just signed this is order nobody
cared emotions yeah yeah this is this no
no and and not just emotions it's
ignorant people with platforms so this
is what worries me man yep
what section 230 reform absolutely that
will change everything it needs to
happen the more we talk about it the
more I look into it's free speech online
needs to be protected people need to
grow a backbone I don't care worry about
yourself so this people need to worry
about themselves way more than what
other people are doing that is we where
did that go so here's the here's the
challenge
mm-hmm I do think it's fair to say this
will be the most important elections of
our lives yep right now absolutely not
because I think this cause is more
important and say the Iraq war or you
know universal health care as Obama's
you know one of his big things because
it will fundamentally change the fabric
of our country and the world if we do
not reform section two
30 to protect legal speech yeah right
now the biggest platforms and their
partners in media control all cultural
institutions which means politics cannot
exist unless the cultural gatekeepers
allow it to yeah if you want to it if
you want to say something like this I
believe we should have a flat tax well
guess what they could ban you for saying
it and you can't do anything about it
and then you have quite literally no
politicians advocating for a flat tax so
who is going to run on that position
nobody right no one will care that idea
will be just will beat will compete be
gone here's the bigger problem this may
be the most important election of our
lives and even if the Republicans win
there is no guarantee they actually do
it they would have to sweep the the
Congress and the presidency gain control
would they even do it they had control
in 2016 they didn't do it now it's I
think it's fair to say you had what
people call Rhinos Republican to name
only right you had a lot of people who
retired who had no interest they were
establishment players the Republican
Party did not want to you know do
anything probably up it and not do
anything yeah they were just keys to the
castle politicians you know but even now
most of them are right now what's you
know is it because we're deadlocked
between the house and the cent that
we're not getting anything done I
honestly don't know so you you you gotta
cross your fingers that come November
not only will you win let's say the
Senate majority does exist and they're
going to go out November in massive
numbers and prove it
but you also are hoping that the
Republicans who get elected will
actually do this I think it's I think
it's a great idea it's been well look no
it's not my idea
the DOJ no I know I've seen it bill Barr
yeah looked into it after that yeah we
first talked about the other day now I'm
not sure he goes far enough cuz he still
says that they should have a good-faith
effort to remove certain content that
means they can still start banning
certain people but it would give you
more legal protections I suppose and the
other issue is that we've already seen
them violate the section 230 Twitter
does it all the time that's true nothing
happens so it's not so look there's a
lot of steps here first
you've the Republicans would have to win
they'd have to put in Section 230 reform
then someone would need a case something
or something would happen where they
would sue and challenge their
protections then Twitter would have a
precedent would be set and Twitter would
would would would you know take action
yeah
so learn to code is the best example
under 230 they're allowed to remove some
content not all it's got to be
objectionable or like harassing or
whatever and people were tweeting things
like learn to code or a good example
would be like James Lindsay James
Lindsay is one of the foremost experts
on critical race theory and locusts and
he just went on Rogan get a ton of
followers they suspended his account
they can still do those things even with
230 reform sorry I gotta ask did you see
the first thing he posted when he got
back no what was it spicy yeah it was
spicy talking about people how do I say
this without saying it why cuz it's bad
you'll get banned I don't want to say it
well it's very it's very specific
subject it's it's I don't want to talk
about it but go go look at it you know
read reading his work well James because
it makes a lot of sense what he's saying
yeah and it's scary actually also so
here's the challenge with section 230
reform they probably would not be able
to ban him by mistake in that in that
way there's the war on ignorant yeah and
also child ignorant yeah so that's all
yeah if if we specifically state in in
the reform 230 that a good-faith effort
to remove illegal content there will
still be some mistakes but that wouldn't
be one of them because there's no reason
to believe and there's no good-faith
belief that he posted anything illegal
right
in which case these accidents would be
few and far between now I could see some
people would find it offensive but
that's just the thing it's some people
can be offended that's their right you
can be offended anyone can be offended
but that doesn't mean you're right
we Lynx Tom McDonald we need more than
this though be
is right now another problem is that we
have fallen to accounts overtly breaking
the law with their posts that's right so
I'm gonna you know I gotta say it there
is one potential solution what's up
the end of anonymity on the internet
that's it so kind of like now people are
upset that parler you have to put in a
number and it's like I kind of am down
with that because you can't go you're
gonna go get like five different numbers
so that you can because you have to
actually they're trying to trick that
BOTS from manipulation yeah that's
awesome I don't I have one person that's
me I don't want you know I don't need
another voice I'm using my own voice I'm
happy with that I'm not trying to
influence you know in and make fake
accounts to like BOTS it up like that's
people do that yeah so that is like
parlor is actually that's pretty legit
so what this would have to come after
reform in a 2:30 form I'm not saying
it's a good idea because they're serious
pros and cons right there are
whistleblowers who can't speak up that
use anonymity to protect themselves and
call out you know malfeasance is a good
point on the other hand there are people
who run 50 accounts to manipulate brands
and to banning people to push ideology
cancel culture exactly so a big solution
to a lot of these problems is an end to
anonymity on social media Facebook
basically did it Facebook said you have
to use your real name from now on oh
really yeah well it was awhile ago
several years ago okay there was a big
controversy because some people use
pseudonyms and some people are activists
who face persecution in their home
countries they've fled and they're like
if I use my real name so and and some
people on Facebook don't use real photos
of themselves but the idea is if
everyone has to stand up for what
they're saying then people would be a
lot less inclined to be awful and nasty
and and it wasn't illegal to just speak
your mind right which is what the reform
would do well you won't get banned for
it okay okay right so some things would
still be illegal to do like death
threats and whatnot so if it's illegal
to leave it right alright so here's the
the the the pendulum that sort of like
the problems and the waves they cause if
we reform to 30 we solve one problem
people can now speak up and we can
rebalance the political conversation
I'm not saying it would favor the
extremes it would not it would favor the
center and reinvigorate the center to
come back and you know for a debate it
would pull the left it would force the
left back to the center because the
bigger conversation will be happening
among more people however this could
result in a massive flood of annoying
really annoying racist tirades brigade
eng sockpuppet ree which can result in
the platform becoming just a cesspool of
chaos this is one of the things that
Twitter was concerned about that the
reason they would they decided to just
take take sides and ban one is that if
they really did mass free speech you end
up with BOTS just spamming everybody all
the time and so they had to figure how
to deal with that so if you have section
230 reformed protecting all legal speech
and you create a platform where you
can't be anonymous
problem solved oh but there's still some
problems you can argue but then
individuals can't run multiple multiple
accounts mm-hmm and they have to stand
behind every word they say
so will you get angry racist tirades
that are really annoying yes you will
but a lot of people do this to be
contrarian that's true they do because
it's funny it's fun they want to troll
you will get rid of a lot of the trolls
I think online trolls is like what
started the Karen movement because
people were thinking that they were it
was real and then they ran with it and
then people started the trolls were like
oh it's working all right now I'm gonna
get more people and then more people
were getting offended and then it's
snowballed into this you know speaking
of the snow plow parents the kids grew
up and were offended and the trolls were
eating him alive and now we're now we're
look where we're at you know I've seen
these feminists retweet trolls on
purpose and it's because they like it
yeah it's a game to a lot of these
people I've seen some high profile
feminists go I can't believe all the
harassment I'm getting look and they
start retweeting them yeah and then I
was I was one person I know and I said
don't you know that retweeting them is
their goal and then the response was do
you expect me to be silenced I will not
be silenced by them and I'm like oh shut
you're you know what you're doing you're
feeding the trolls on purpose because it
gets positive attention for you can play
the victim and welcome to you know 2020
we are you know 36 years off but I guess
we finally made it here this retreat
being renamed you know records being
falsified was born in 84 what does it
mean
1984 what does it mean the year I was
born welcome to the resistance brother
to all of you watching right now it may
be there is a silent majority they may
be lying in wait ready to pounce onto
that voting voter booth now they wanted
they want to do it legally there they're
law-abiding citizens yes but for now we
can't make that assumption we don't know
how many oh I'm making the assumption
but all we can really do for now is
determine one thing if there ever was an
actual resistance this is it not them
not them complaining with the orange man
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you